Legend tells of many ancient weapons
many of them imbued with great power
hammers that call forth the very forces
of the heavens themselves raining down
devastating thunderstorms and
electrifying boats of lightning to
Vanquish any foe or there's the
Arthurian myth of a blade buried deep in
the heart of a stone to any ordinary
person the sword is unmovable it won't
budge no matter how much force is
exerted on it or how physically strong
the person trying to pull it is only if
one of purest heart and truest virtue
should ever reach for its Hilt then the
sword Will Spring free and Grant the
holder the rightful rule over the land
but there is another weapon another
sword bestowed with a power as old as
time itself some have heard tales that
it was forged of pure Shadow by a demon
seeking minion over all creation other
stories will claim the blade itself is
alive and capable of bonding itself to a
host while it grants its wielder the
means to fell an entire army with a
swing of its Blade the weapon also
curses those who seek to covet its
destructive power slowly destroying them
the longer they possess this Unholy
sword such a powerful tool of
Devastation would bring chaos on this
world than any other but this
well this is not that sword at all
actually the weapon in question even
though it technically doesn't count as
one isn't some magical item in fact it's
only real power is causing all of its
various owners over the years to end up
needing a serious trip to the ER so this
is
scp-572 okay sorry I'll do the voice
again but this is the last time or as
the legend call it the katana of
apparent invincibility now just like the
ancient weapons of Legend This Katana
has changed hands a number of times over
the course of human history one of those
to wield its completely unincredible
power was Jonathan a young man with high
hopes of going viral online as a master
swordsman however While most would only
ever gain that title after Year's worth
of study practicing complex hand-to-hand
combat forms and learning to respect the
blade itself and the craftsmanship used
in making one Jonathan just read a
wikiHow tutorial on sword tricks and
deciding they looked easy enough decided
that he could just wing it of course the
first step in becoming a master
swordsman without putting in any of the
work was to find an actual sword to use
and luckily the pawn shop in Jonathan's
Hometown had the very answer to his low
effort dreams hanging there behind the
counter displayed on the top shelf with
a thin layer of dust coating was the
katana of apparent invincibility the
store's owner had long since forgotten
it was even there and was happy enough
to Mark the price down for the sake of
getting rid of it the moment he held it
in his hands Jonathan felt Unstoppable
like he could conquer his whole town
with the power of this mighty sword that
was barely sharp enough to cut wet
toilet paper he knew it would only take
one show of the weapon's very arguable
might to cement him as one of History's
Greatest Swordsmen unfortunately the
stunt that Jonathan attempted went about
as well as you'd expect naturally an
elaborate stunt involving a blunt Katana
and Jonathan's friend Kali on a BMX bike
was sure to be a perfectly safe
combination any sane human being would
tell you that right after setting up his
phone at the skate park and hitting
record Jonathan called for Kali to ride
down on one side of the half pipe and up
the other while he used his Newfound
sword skills to cleave the front wheel
of her bike clean off in mid-air having
been promised a replacement bike paid
for by all the hits this video would get
online Cali went down then up then
straight back down Jonathan swung the
blade only for it to get lodged in the
wheel spokes bringing his friend and the
solid frame of her bike crashing down on
top of him in a heap of Tangled Limbs
and metal all the while nearby skaters
filmed the mess on their phones the ones
who could hold back their laughs anyway
sometime after the skatepark debacle
scp-572 would end up in the hands of yet
another would-be swordsman with just as
impressive results Martin zippelberger
yes that is his real name had grown into
quite a controversial figure over the
years garnering his own Legend of sorts
although not a reputation that any
mythical Warrior of old would ever want
you see Martin had founded a website
that had in its earlier days introduced
the internet to a brand new way of
communicating and keeping in touch with
their friends and family and as a result
he had accumulated a staggering amount
of cash to show for it but running a
social media app didn't keep the lights
on forever despite his company growing
into a multi-million dollar Corporation
the market had become saturated more new
and Innovative sites run by Martin's
competitors began appearing each new one
more unique than his had ever been back
in the early days keeping up and still
making money was hard so Martin resorted
to Gathering the personal data of
millions of users his site had amassed
over the years and selling that
information too well anyone who would
pay him understandably people were a
little upset to hear that all their
private information was being shared
around so brazenly that's when rumors of
Martin's interesting Behavior started to
be made public by some of his former
employees the internet had already been
Rife with jokes at Martin's expense his
stunted manner of speaking strange
barbecuing live streams filmed in front
of what looked like a green screen along
with many other quirks were often the
subject of ridicule some even speculated
that he would was a collector of various
things a robot an alien even an iguana
and pretending to be a human being then
there was his choice of office equipment
specifically a certain Katana of
apparent invincibility given his
considerable net worth the programmers
working in the head offices of Martin's
social media company knew he had
somewhat expensive tastes that was what
made it all the more baffling that he
bought what looked to be a very poor
quality Western knockoff of a
traditional Japanese Samurai weapon the
metal it was forged from seemed to be
unpolished unsharpened and unbalanced
overall it just seemed to be a bit of a
mess even to those in the office
unfamiliar with katanas or their
cultural significance in Japan yet when
he described it Martin seemed enamored
with the sword citing how incredible the
balance was and how the obviously very
blunt weapon could more easily slice
through solid steel than one of those
infomercial knives of course the more
pressing and settling question for most
of the employees was why the hell did
their boss think it was okay to bring a
katana into the office when any of the
staff working there built up enough
courage to approach their eccentric
sword toting boss to ask him Martin
would simply state that it was a measure
to encourage more productivity if he was
unhappy with the coding work his
programmers were doing or the content
being posted to his social media site
Martin would start strutting around the
office his head was always tilted back
smugly looking down his nose at his
staff who he'd sometimes affectionately
call his underlings or drones with the
look of self-important superiority in
one hand constantly resting on the hilt
of his Katana his productivity patrols
managed to put everyone in the office on
edge less because they were threatened
by the blunted sword or Martin's
unimposing five and a half foot stature
but more because the staff all agreed
that what he was doing was just plain
weird one morning Ned one of the staff
members working at the office was
casually sitting at his computer working
his way through rewriting a few lines of
code as he's been asked to suddenly he
felt something cold and metal resting on
his shoulder and felt the presence of
someone leaning over him uncomfortably
close on the left immediately his heart
jumped in Surprise and fear only to
instantly drop back down to a normal
beat when he remembered that Martin's
sword was barely sharper than a butter
knife hey Mr zippleburger Ned's side hey
there nedring Martin replied his voice
sounded like he was trying to smile but
also didn't know how long it was normal
to hold it also Ned's name wasn't short
for nedri you know you were asked to
finish up this coating an hour ago he
continued even though Ned had only been
told the code needed rewriting that long
ago if you don't hurry up I might just
have to chop you into bits with my huge
sword Martin forced to laugh as though
he'd never actually expressed humor
before eventually the employees had
grown sick of Martin's brandishing his
Katana around
they didn't feel threatened so much as
they were just annoyed it was
distracting them from actually doing
their jobs when a group of them led by
Ned marched into his office to formally
complain in solidarity Martin spun
around to face them in his desk chair
his useless sword in his hand so this is
treason there he smiled to himself as if
he'd been waiting for this moment
drawing the katana in his head Martin
was about to Leap Forward over his desk
in a move ripped straight out of a Star
Wars movie he thought he would easily
spin through the air hurtling towards
his group of employees with the blade
ready to skewer the nearest ones for
daring to question his leadership
unfortunately despite his surfing trips
in Hawaii Martin wasn't exactly Nimble
enough to pull it off he barely jumped
high enough off the ground to clear the
desk knocking the whole thing forward
and tumbling over it Landing awkwardly
the tip of the blade barely reached far
enough to lightly graze Ned at the front
of the group instead all of Martin's
employees looked at him pathetically
laying face down on the office carpet
after changing fans who knows exactly
how many times the katana of apparent
invincibility would soon find itself in
the hands of another Soul just as worthy
of wielding it and making themselves
look really dumb in the process for as
long as he could remember Zach had been
obsessed with superheroes he had spent
his youth reading comic books idolizing
characters like Batman who fought
criminals on the Mean Streets to deliver
Swift and brutal Justice even as he got
older Zach never outgrew that childhood
dream he had held on to to become a
real-life superhero now obviously he
knew that superhuman Powers were a
little out of his reach but that never
stopped Bruce Wayne Zach could train
himself build up his physical strength
and learn to fight of course he
overlooked the part where Bruce Wayne
also had billions of dollars inherited
from his parents at his disposal not to
mention a cave with lots of fancy
high-tech gadgets and English butler and
it trained under some of the most
skilled hand-to-hand combatants in the
entire world Batman never learned karate
during night classes held at the local
Community College still there was
nothing that could deter Zach from his
heroic aspirations he spent every free
moment he had in the gym lifting weights
and building his biceps to the size of
burger buns after failing his exam twice
he achieved the coveted blue belt in his
martial arts class and he even ordered
the parts he would need to construct his
super suit sure Zach told himself it
might have just looked like a ski mask
and some hockey pads but he needed
freedom of movement as well as
protection there was only one piece left
to complete this stage of his origin
story a kick-ass superhero code name
that was when fate seemed to step in
taking its rarest of forms an eBay
listing for a used sword from the moment
he sought Zack knew he needed to own it
not all superheroes used weapons but he
figured it would be a good deterrent
he'd only ever draw his blade to wound
and only when there was no other option
as he placed his bed Captain Katana was
born it was his first nightly Patrol
Zach had donned his protective suit and
concealed his secret identity behind the
mask the katana was sheathed and
strapped to his back for now but he was
sure enough it would soon see its share
of righteous Vengeance before the night
was over well more accurately it would
cause more than a share of mishaps by
the end of the night but Zack sorry
Captain Katana didn't care he felt
Unstoppable in fact ever since the sword
had arrived in the mail he had been
feeling like he could take on the world
the would-be hero thought it was just
the anticipation of finally being what
he'd always wanted to be exactly what
his training had been preparing for how
is he to know that the sword itself was
the reason for his dangerous amount of
overconfidence you see while it might
not be imbued with ancient magic the
power of a God or the ability to suck
the souls of its victims there is one
thing remarkable about
scp-572 okay well two things the first
being just how bad it is as a sword it
isn't forged from any high quality steel
or made by an elusive Japanese
swordsmith whereas a katana made with
the proper amount of skill craftsmanship
and Care is perfectly weighted and
balanced evenly for the right amount of
speed and swiftness in combat this one
is well none of the above and as if it
wasn't bad enough that it lacked all the
other qualities of a true katana
scp-572's blade is totally blunt
seriously you couldn't even slice bread
with this thing and yet in his heart
Zach felt like it was the perfect weapon
the most powerful tool in this vigilante
war on crime speaking of crimes he
thought he'd found his first prey for
his nightly hunt the sound of a car
alarm was blaring through the city
streets coming from somewhere nearby our
woefully under equipped and
underprepared hero raced a few blocks
over to find the source from a distance
all he could see was a man fumbling with
the door of a locked car clearly unable
to open it and trying to force his way
in what this so-called hero didn't think
to do was assess the situation for any
further context too quick to trust in
his instincts
he declared unable to hear how muffled
his voice sounded when filtered through
the material of the ski mask the man
froze and turned to look at the figure
approaching him only to raise an eyebrow
in confusion ah hello he called back can
I help you silence villain the Mast
onlooker shouted just oddly over the
noisy Car Alarm we've got two choices
here either you walk away leave that
person's property alone and I'll let you
off with a warning or we do this the
hard way and you'll face Zach paused for
dramatic effect like he practiced in the
mirror but Wrath of Captain Katana of
who the other man replied look man I'm
not sure what your deal is if this is
some kind of cosplay thing or you're
just nuts but this is my car okay the
door gets stuck I just need to Jimmy it
a little sometimes but it sets the alarm
off wire Captain Katana yelled reaching
over his shoulder his gloved hand
gripped the hilt of his weapon and
pulled it free of its sheath from across
the parking lot the driver couldn't tell
how utterly useless the sword was at his
current distance all he saw was amassed
potentially unhinged stranger
dramatically pacing towards him with
what was very clearly a weapon what the
hell he exclaimed urgently trying to get
his car door open the handle gave way
and the door sprung open allowing the
man to hurriedly climb into the driver's
seat and shut the door behind him
starting the engine the lights came on
and illuminated The Stranger in front of
him who stood looking absolutely
ridiculous in his outfit consisting of
what looked like various pieces of
sportswear Katana and hand the superhero
was still striding slowly towards the
car as the engine spluttered into life
Zack stopped smiling under the material
of his hockey
as he gripped both hands around the hilt
and took a wide stance flooring the
accelerator the driver was eager to get
away from the obvious lunatic even if he
was wielding a sword that was mostly
unusable it didn't seem like that would
stop Captain Katana from trying to use
it no matter how unsuccessfully the car
came barreling towards Zach and he
readied himself lifting the blade high
above his head he knew that he would be
able to bring it downwards in a
Victorious swipe at precisely the right
moment the second the worn out dulled
metal connected with that of the car it
would slice the stolen vehicle into two
perfect pieces split right down the
middle leaving the thief confounded and
ready to be handed over to police you
can already guess that's not what
happened can you with barely a screech
of tires against the concrete and
without even enough distance to build up
that much speed the car headed straight
for Captain Katana he made a flailing
uncoordinated swing far too early
causing the sword to bounce right off
the hood of the car the force of the
impact wasn't huge but it was enough to
cause the katana to slip from the
wannabe Hero's hands helped by the fact
his gloves didn't have that much grip on
them the katana of apparent
invincibility was sent sailing through
the air and came clattering to the
ground rolling under another car in the
parking lot although Zach was a little
preoccupied to see where it landed no
sooner had he lost his grip on his
Almighty weapon of Justice around three
and a half thousand pounds of metal
collided with Captain Katana felled on
his first ever night as a superhero by
his very first villain still Zach at
least learned what his Kryptonite was
his greatest weakness just like so many
classic superheroes had his just
happened to be being hit by a midsize
sedan tumbling back onto the ground the
back of Captain katana's head thumped
heavily against the cold hard concrete
leaving him with a concussion and an
overwhelming sense of embarrassment as
the driver parked his car and called an
ambulance at least he now knew he never
wanted to pick up that sword
you see that's the second remarkable
thing about
scp-572 anyone who picks it up instantly
perceives it as a mighty weapon the kind
you would find in an ancient legend
despite the sword being crudely made
blunt and generally unfit for any use
the wielder will maintain the belief
that it not only has perfect balance and
cutting power but that the sword has
also imbued them with unparalleled
strength and invincibility to damage
it's all a delusion of course and
whoever holds that sword will gladly
prove it to you they'll try to perform
incredibly risky stunts with it only to
end up severely injuring themselves in
the process don't worry though if you
ever come across scp-572 it's nothing a
quick thump in the back of the head
won't fix now if you want to hear about
an actual all-powerful sword that can
obliterate anything on an atomic level
as well as the ancient energy being who
wields it then you should go and check
out scp-001 the gate guardian and of
course sometimes the only thing better
than one Katana is two tanas and an
Infamous comic book character but will
that be enough to take on the hard to
destroy reptile find out in Deadpool
versus scp-682